Speaker 1: . Some of you who have been watching
the show for a long time might remember the viral
video we did many years ago called something
like to protest racism, white students banned
from going on campus or something like that. We
have sort of another weird version of this, which
is that I guess to protest racism or to try to
repair from some prior racism, there is an event
forcing only white attendees to pay. And
I'm going to give you my best understanding
of what's going on here and then we're going
to talk about it. But as I understand it,
this is one of these examples of sort of like
when when the left just gets it completely wrong.
This is an article from my Northwest Dotcom
talking about a gay pride event in Seattle
that will charge only white people admission as
a sort of reparation fee. Let's read about it.
Organizers for a Seattle gay pride event say
they're charging white people a reparations fee
to attend. They have the support of Seattle City
Council president and mayoral candidate Lorena
Gonzalez and the Seattle Human Rights Commission
taking black pride. Organizers say all are welcome
to attend, however, white allies and accomplices.
This is already just problematic language. This
this is this is like the worst of the worst. Must
pay the reparations fee. It will be charged on a
sliding scale of 10 to 50 dollars, depending
on one's ability to pay. Well, at least it's
based on a sliding scale of economics and not like
how white you are, where if, like you're sort of
white, it's 10 bucks. But if you're really white,
it's 50 bucks. The event location is Jimi Hendrix
Park, owned by the city of Seattle. This raises
questions about the legality of a reparations fee.
Critics question whether race based admission
fees are appropriate. Hint, they're not.
Seattle Municipal Code clearly prohibits racial
discrimination, but organizers have pushed back,
calling criticism of their admission structure
casual violence. This is, my friends,
the epitome of what I have pointed out as
the remember, guys, I'm not a right winger.
I'm a critic of this stuff from the left. This
is the epitome of the problem with some of this
post-structuralist post-modernist. And I'm not
going Jordan Peterson on you guys. This isn't
this is not a specific issue of every narrative
is valid and any critique can be called out as
racist itself. And this is you know, I've talked
about critical race theory before. I think there's
lots of valuable aspects to an understanding of
the view that critical race theory puts forward.
But one of the things that's hugely problematic is
if you disagree with any aspect of critical race
theory, you are by default racist or a white
supremacist or whatever, even if you're just,
you know, a Hispanic immigrant from South America
like me. And this is exactly an example of that,
that if you criticize this. A structure of white
people are the only ones who have to pay to go to
the event, that is a form of violence against
presumably minorities. This is gutter stuff.
We solve nothing if with if this is the prevailing
view, it's not the prevailing view, fortunately.
Let's look here at a letter actually that was
written about written about this dear city of
Seattle. This is from Charlotte Lafave and Philip
Lipson from Capitol Hill. They say it's come to
our attention that an event called Take Black
Pride at the Jimi Hendrix Public Park June 26th
is charging whites only admission as reparations.
We consider this reverse discrimination in its
worst form and we feel we are being attacked for
not supporting due to disparaging and hostile
emails. Please review this event stated admission
policy as we feel it violates Seattle King County,
state and federal equality laws. Additionally,
we would like you to investigate the event as
a possible ethics and elections violation, as
Take Black Pride is hosted by Nikki Etienne,
a campaign manager for Nikita Oliver. OK, that's
another issue. And the way it's written is
all are free to attend. However, this is a black
and brown, queer, trans centered, prioritized,
valued event. Safety of black and brown, trans
and queer folk is paramount. We will make
sure their safety is prioritized at all times.
Great. We want everybody to be safe. White allies
and accomplices are welcome to attend, but will be
charged a ten to fifty dollar reparation fee and
given a wristband as proof of payment that will
be used to keep this event free of costs for black
and brown and trans queer community. But to ensure
performers can be paid as well, we will never
charge admission over the color of a person's
skin, and we resent being attacked for standing
in those values. So they're kind of playing coy
and saying we're not charging admission based on
perceived race. We're charging a reparations
fee based on perceived race. And by the way,
we are giving a wristband. What's the point
of the wristband? If you're there and you see
someone you believe is white walking around, you
might wonder, did they pay their reparations fee
or did they sneak in? They will be flagged in
a sense, so that as you identify people that
you believe to be white, you'll know if they paid
their fee from the wristband. And you can think of
some historical analogies to such a wristband on
the basis of race. I won't even mention them. OK,
this is just this is absolutely crazy. OK,
forget about the logistics of who decides if
you look white enough to be asked whether you're
white. What about light skinned Puerto Ricans?
What about folks from Brazil who are of mixed
race? But look white. What if your alibiing
actually had an albino Puerto Rican friend and the
conversations that that he would would end up in?
This is just the worst of the worst of the worst.
And, you know, I even take issue with the term
reverse discrimination, much like I've taken
issue with the term reverse racism. If you're
discriminating on the basis of race where you have
to pay, if you are or appear to be white, it's
not reverse anything. It's just discrimination.
And this is the type of thing where, you know,
there are so many good faith activists of all
kinds on the left with different perspective,
the perspective there are good faith, social
democratic activists. There are good faith
socialists, even though I'm not a socialist there,
there's all this stuff and then this and then
this, which just goes against every true notion
of what it means to have a functioning progressive
society. And the question I always have is carried
to its full conclusion. How does this solve
whatever problem it is you were trying to solve
with this policy? If you disagree with me, if
there is anybody in my audience who thinks this is
a good idea, let me know. I want to hear from you